he was in the middle of nowhere with the
next time being five miles ahead of me
and immediately he said i got a phone
call as a runner what are you doing here
what's the point of this and i said oh
i'm actually running across the country
he said for what so why got me scared
when he put his hand on his gun
you know i've had robbie on the show
obviously i also had ricky gates on who
shared his
experience running across america
self-supported which is a very different
thing
um but a key difference here is that
these are two white dudes right and
they're they're out there they're
vulnerable
they're in parts of the world you know
and they're in many
in so many ways if you're gonna do this
you're relying on the kindness of
strangers yeah right
yeah you're as far as i know you're the
first
yeah black person yeah do this solo yeah
so um i
i did research to figure out so back in
the i think
1928 there are these i think it was
four three or four runners i'm not sure
so they were running across the country
but
they were doing a relay so it was right
you know it used to be a race
yeah it was a race yeah yeah it was it's
literally called black dudes
america or something yeah yeah yeah
they're actually kicking out some of the
the black runner color runners they're
like you're not doing this
but they did a thing where it was a
relay so like
let's say me and you did a relay
together you do a certain amount of
distance so i'm the first solo black
person in the history of the country to
run from la to new york city
did you know that going into this going
into it i had a conversation with robbie
robbie actually brought up to me
say hello i don't know i think he might
be the first i haven't seen and robbie
was making sure he's doing his research
so we don't come out and make such a
statement and it's not true
but um yeah i i started thinking about
as a as i was going
and that's when i kind of got a little
nervous with some of the things that was
happening in the country
so i asked robbie so i called him one
day i said hey what was your
biggest fear so in my mind i wasn't even
thinking
um anything else but i was just thinking
about being a color person
so he was telling me about the dog
situation right away and i brought up
the the whole
like should i feel um not safe for who i
am
and then i knew that was something that
i was concerned of and
and you can see why you were concerned
when you're in a certain part of the
country
but overall i tried not to put my energy
into it so my mentality is if you put
your energy into something that's what's
going to happen you're going to matter
yeah you're coming into just positive
people and i would say
majority of that 95 of the time that's
what that was the case right
you did have a few run-ins so yeah i had
a few run-ins um
the the first one actually happened in
oklahoma which was really scary for me
uh as i so when we're in california and
arizona
i've had these awesome police officers
hey you're the guy on tick tock i saw
you on instagram can i take a picture
with you
i remember this officer i saw him one
day outside of
flagstaff arizona and then 30 miles
later he saw me the next day he goes
whoa you're really making progress and
he asked um bill
is it okay if i stop hella to take a
picture is he gonna be mad and i was
like no
i'm not gonna be mad so he came in i was
like yes thank you so much i was always
taking pictures with them
and one of the officers coming in
oklahoma and i
i thought it was similar thing maybe
they know what i'm doing so i'm excited
i'm running actually i was cruising that
day
i'm like i have my stick i'm like
smiling and then i see the officer come
out
i thought he knew what i was doing but
everything kind of got serious
immediately i can
see it so he just said hey sir i just
got a phone call there's a runner in the
world what are you doing out here
and with the the seriousness of the
voice i was like i don't think he's
very happy right now and immediately is
it a busy road i mean a charitable
interpretation would be
that you know like why is this guy out
here like it's
unsafe it was in the middle of nowhere
not much traffic to a point where like
belle could be next to me for most of
the time
if anything she's a little behind or a
little ahead it wasn't that busy it was
in the middle of nowhere with the next
time being five miles ahead of me
and immediately he said i got a phone
call as a runner what are you doing
right here what's the point of this and
i said oh
i'm actually running across the country
he said for what so why got me scared
when he put his hand on his gun
and then you know that there's like a
clip yeah and then the little box
so i started panicking and i put my
stick up i said oh this is just a
running pole it helps me get up the
hills and see i'm wearing my safety vest
i want people to see me i'm doing it for
a non-profit and i just started telling
the story
and i started waving belling and i was
scared to wave belle in early because
i didn't want him to think that you're
getting somebody i'm getting help
and now he has to be uh protective of
himself so i was scared so i kind of
waited even a little longer to wave her
in because
she was actually thinking later to find
out she thought it was just an officer
just seeing if i was okay
or because it's been the case and i see
these couple far
uh and these are two couples and i i was
like this is weird i think they're
waiting for me so they got impatient
with my interaction with the police
officer
at that point he was asking can i see
your id say well my id is in my rv five
miles ahead i gotta get to that
and then he said what's your birthday
give me your name and he just started
asking me all these things he was a
little annoyed but these couple came in
um these white couple came in and
they're like are you hella or some told
us about you we're tracking you down we
want to donate they had a
money for me they want to take pictures
then i see the officer
buying into the story i can just see
he's like oh he is actually doing this
for real
like you literally can see it and i was
like thank god these people came in so
they can attest to what i'm doing
because they've been tracking and
following me and
uh and i was waving belling at that
point so she came in she would come in
with a camera all the time to get
content
and the officer asked me and can i also
get a picture
yeah and i was like it just turned it
turned into a positive
and thank god that happened that was
scary um it's kind of heavy man
yeah it's heavy that this you know that
a couple white people had to come in
yeah in order for this guy to feel okay
about what was happening and when he
left
it hit me i was shook i couldn't move
for like 10 minutes i was on the side of
the road
i was like wait because i just started
thinking why was he touching his gun
and the reason i raised my pull because
i'm thinking i hope
no one thinks that's a weapon or rifle i
don't know so you just start thinking
all these things
so i was shook a little bit and that was
um
tough and also and actually in
around in california i had this lady
i think the lady was a little cuckoo she
this lady goes by in a jeep and
she offered me water say hey do you want
some water to drink i said oh no i'm
good thank you that's my supporter
actually i got my water in there
and this lady also is coming out he was
screaming at that car for offering
water and then she goes what do you
think you're doing i said
i'm running across the country she said
for what i said for a non-profit called
soul facility she goes well that's
[ __ ] you're about to get caught up
now
i was like wait she joking sounds like
bell wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
this i was like well wait wait i don't
know if she's jerking gonna unlock the
car
and then i'm across the street and she's
on the other side and she started
charging sprinting and there's a
gentleman next to her she's like come
i thought it was her boyfriend she's
calling her dog to come so i just
sprinted into the car
and belle did a u-turn it was the
fastest youtuber i've ever seen her do
and we just whipped around and she
started to chase the car and i see her
and
i'm turning around she's chasing the car
and we
she couldn't keep up so i was kind of i
was thinking my head there's no way she
can catch me right now my leg was good
enough to run faster than her
but i'm like if she has a weapon or a
gun i can't run that
so we called an officer and we waited
two hours
the nearest officer was like almost an
hour away so we waited two hours
officer like her that was her last name
she's so close oh like her i like that
last name
she came and escorted us and by the time
she got there they were gone but we just
wanted to be safe
and not to get through that area so that
was in california that was in california
beginning
and a lot of people were wanting us to
be careful there yeah
and last sad story uh i don't like to
talk about society so much
was uh missouri missouri was one of
those states where it was
to begin with i was already like i don't
like missouri because of snakes
literally people asking me have you 76 i
was like no there's
snakes nowhere and when we get into
missouri snakes on side of the roads on
the grass
everywhere in front of you you can see
roadkill is really sad to see that
so i'm like i don't wanna one of them
jumped in front of me too and i panicked
and screamed and just took off so that
was already in the back of my mind i'm
running i'm like looking at the side of
the road
i hope there's no snake and i go by
owensville high school um
and school was just getting i was around
2 30 2 40 p.m
all the bunch of kids pulling out of the
parking lot so um
me whenever i see cars i would always
wave like i said just give good energy
some cars won't kind of
they kind of move so far over even over
the white line you feel like you're
gonna get hit so
i'm always trying to keep tight and also
waving at people
um i'm here but also hey hi how are you
doing
and i see these uh this truck pulls and
then
it was a bunch of teenagers a bunch of
boys in the back of the truck and
the pickup truck has a window that rolls
down in the back windshield
so i saw one of the kids took their head
out and called me the n-word i was so
shocked i was like
wait did this just happen so i'm just
like come on what was the point of this
so belle across the street thought they
were going to hit me because sometimes
that happens
so she just honks all the time to warn
people she just thought i was one of
those
and they just and the kid ducks down and
floors it
and just took off and i i'm pretty sure
a parent saw it because
she definitely felt bad she came back
around to wave at me and basically said
hey
i'm sorry that happened so that happened
in missouri
so that was really and i got flipped off
a little bit in missouri prior to that
so
that was not a fun day in missouri yeah
yeah i'm sorry about that yeah that that
happened
but overall people were charitable what
i realized there's so many more good
people in the world than bad
and it makes you feel like we have a
promising world because so many
awesome people that don't even know who
i am are offering me water
they're offering me rides to a point
where like i was denying rides
one lady comes to me and say well i
won't tell anybody and i was like no
that would be cheating
like that's how good people were
bringing gatorade they're like well i
saw you i'm like you're
running you're doing you're not just
running a female it looks like you're
going somewhere far
so they're bringing me water and so many
good people so many
[Music]
[Music]
you